I love t-shirts yes this is a new one
but it's going it's going into a
rotation oh my god I love it I love your
old man you look good thank you how you
been good artist of the decade yeah it's
been that's pretty well
you know when they that was incredible
the Academy country music let told me
that we were gonna be the artists of the
decade and I kind of just felt like but
it was kind of weird you know I felt
like I felt like I hadn't been around
long enough to to get something like
that then I kind of turned her at well
you know it was like I looked and it was
like 14 years so I was like well I guess
I have been around over a decade but it
was it was one of the biggest honors of
my career Amy you've had like the
biggest songs you have the best
catalogue and I was telling them you
make it easy I know I wrote that in the
letter to back say I love that song well
thank you like I want my husband to slow
dance in the rain with me - that's not
it it's a sexy song y'all so here's my
question oh we asked earlier though and
I know you know Christmas coming up
what's the worst gift you've ever
received the worst gift I think was a
couple years ago I got a motion sensored
light that hangs on your toilet right so
when you stumble into the bathroom at
night it's dark this thing comes on and
it lights up the toilet so you don't
miss we moved and somehow it came up
missing those but it was probably the
honest gift I ever got that is amazing I
kind of want to meet that person but you
were on stage actually and and this is
more of a serious thing but actually I
had friends at the Vegas shooting they
were Brian my actually brain and best
friend my husband's best friend he and
his wife were there at the Vegas
shooting when it happened when you were
doing his show and everything and I just
I know you just did a show in Vegas
recently like
kind of I don't know I guess it was it
what was the point of you doing that
because I want right when that happened
and our friends were literally texting
us during the shooting and we're like
what and I it terrified me to ever go on
stage and I've been on stage forever but
it just scares you because you're so
vulnerable yeah I mean it's you know
obviously something that I wouldn't wish
on anybody and and you know I think for
us going back to Vegas was something
that I think we wanted to do it the
right way we didn't want to go in and
try and do it too soon we felt like
there was going to be a lot of people at
our show that probably haven't been to
one of our shows maybe haven't been to a
concert at all since that show and if
they were going to come back out and you
know that was part of the healing
process for them you know we wanted to
make it a safer environment something
that made them feel safer yeah so we did
Park MGM and and so you know little five
thousand seat arena that you know the
other one was outside thirty forty
thousand people whatever it was and and
so this was a little smaller a little
more intimate where people could come
hopefully feel a little more at ease and
hopefully help some of them I mean we
had to kind of get on stage the next
week you know and start trying to get
through all of it so right off the bat
did you talk to anyone cuz I'm telling
you what uh you know the best thing that
has been kids yes saying like it's not
just you going out there Eva family yeah
it's I mean it was it was rough I think
the best thing that could have happened
was the fact not that could have
happened but the best thing for me was
the fact that my wife was there went
through it my band was there and went
through it my crew everybody and so we
kind of leaned on each other you know
for that stuff and talked through it you
know nobody kind of kept it bottled up I
mean if you had a had a breakdown you
kind of had it in front of everybody and
everybody knew what was going on you
know my wife you know we could talk and
she understood you know what was going
on because she was there you know and so
it was just I think to me that probably
helped more than anything but you know
we're on the other side of it now and
and you know we're part of the root not
any one family now so it's a it's a cool
group it is it is it's a good
so you're a busy dad with two little
kids as well this photo kind of sums it
up here we go yeah now is that what's on
you there Jason
that's puke yeah that's that kind of
stuff happens whenever I take them to do
anything like by myself yes I thought I
mean so that's that's the time they'll
have diarrhea yeah yeah she threw up on
me that day
and then the next time I took her I we
were like five miles from the house and
I started smelling something so I was
like all right maybe it's not that bad
you know I get home and it's coming out
of the diaper into the car seat which
anybody with kids knows there's like a
lot of little nooks and crannies in a
car seat yes we're Cheerios you know I'm
holding her out like this like trying to
get her in the house and take this car
seat and use the water hose and spray it
off it's you know you need a power
washer for that no no um he's starting
to be a big talker he's he's saying
everything he hears right now it says oh
yeah their three-year-old [ __ ] he
repeats everything so be careful I know
trust me I I say stuff and then oh my
god is it do you just want to eat him
that's so cute that's actually been a
little while bet he's got like real kind
of longer hair now oh my god he's
awesome you react to your music he loves
it he came out he's seen a couple shows
he's usually in bed by the time I play
so but I've had a couple things where
he's been able to come out and and and
watch and you know he just he's a little
confused he's like he's got a so when he
was born I had a bunch of posters
pictures of people that I've worked with
I don't have you though but I should do
that but it's like but it's even so it's
like Luke Bryan at George Strait Aranda
and CSP born and so and I had them some
big pictures to him and one of them is
from me and I signed it to him and and
so he looks at the picture and he's like
dad and he looks at me he's like dad dad
- like he knows I'm the same person
but he still hasn't quite put it
together so but they seem I mean he
seems to be you know into the music and
you know you turn it on and he knows
it's me singing so it's funny when it
starts to click
yes cuz then you'll turn around and mike
my kid well like especially river she's
five now she'll turn around and show her
people cheering or whatever and she's
tarnished cuz that's my mom I'm like
slow your roll like she's proud of it
that'll come when she's 16 yeah but you
also have two older daughters that I
know and love
are they Musical at all my oldest
daughter Kili is Kealing Kendall my
oldest one Kili has started playing
guitar and started wanting to play and
so I was like alright well I can teach
you you know you want to play I mean I
play rhythm guitar and I'm like you
wanted to learn to play when I play and
she's like no not really
she said I said well what do you want to
know what do you how you want to play
and she goes I want to play like slash
from Guns & Roses
yeah and she's actually doing great man
she picked it up a lot quicker than I
thought and she's you know got another
year of high school and then you know
sound for college so she wants to go do
something with music so we'll see we'll
see you were scary you both ya know it's
exciting that you know that that she
kind of has the bug and and loves music
it's yeah it's that kindred spirit but
at the same time you're like oh beware
yeah it's just you know it's a tough
business you know and you gotta have
pretty thick skin but you know I love
the fact that she's picked it up and you
know just the fact that she could play
an instrument to me is cool so yeah yeah
I didn't know this story but I didn't
know that you're realizing him wasn't
all themed yeah so my last name is
Williams
okay very different but yes so when I
was in high school and started playing
music there was a couple basketball
players named Jason Williams and so and
there was a piano guy in Nashville named
Jason Dee Williams so it's just so
common you know and so I started using
my middle name which was Aldean and my
grandfather who I was named after my
grandfather and so I had a cousin in
town the other day and we started
talking about him and and my uncle years
ago had
started taking my grandfather out and he
would just record you know had a little
recorder and he would record
conversations and he put him on a CD so
I've been driving around in my truck
listen to those CDs and and my cousin
was in town oh you're talking about him
and and so that night I just kind of had
the feels as you say exactly did you cry
no I didn't but it's just cool I was
named after him and it was the name
growing up that I was like and always
whenever somebody called me Jason Aldean
it was usually cuz I was in trouble yes
so little did I know that that would be
the name that everybody would know me as
you know from now on and he didn't live
long enough to to kind of see that you
know so I was just kind of thinking
about him a lot that night and but then
I ended up naming my only son after him
to Memphis Audi and so yeah such a cool
name thank you such a strong rock'n'roll
name this is this is awesome and I love
that it's smoke yeah
so 9:00 what's the significance sewn on
for me this was an album I know it's
your 9th album yeah its ninth album but
for me this was an album that years ago
I just kind of it was a pipe dream but I
always said if I ever made nine records
I was gonna call it nine or number nine
because I played a lot of baseball
growing up I actually thought that was
gonna be my career path for a long time
and and nine was my number that I wore
playing baseball all those years and so
oh look at 80 beauty Jason oh there you
go
there you go high school and no facial
hair right yeah but tell us about the
album and this is cool art do so with it
what is different cuz I know like I've
made like I think like eight by now but
like you start to go what do i do that's
different
alright album so what do you think is
different well I think that's the thing
is you know after making so many records
you have to you know kind of go in and
get creative and a lot of times you feel
like man I've already done this I've
already done that and you know for me
luckily I mean my influences are all
over the place I mean I'm from Macon
Georgia which is a home of the Allman
Brothers and Otis Redding and Little
Richard and but you know songs for me
like dirt road anthem and those kind of
things I mean those were those came from
me like in different genres of music and
and it's kind of the same on this record
I mean I think for me I want to go in
and make albums where there's going to
be some traditional country songs
because I love
that stuff there's going to be some you
know more arm beef type stuff and rock
and roll is a huge thing you make it
easy there is one okay the song on their
code I got what I got okay man
yeah so I think that'll be your James
Spotify knows I stalk you
they all are watching us beware I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this